maintenant tour h4 a aussi ses avantages
puisque tours en h4 menace la faible
menace directe de venir prendre le pion
h 6
avec une attaque gagnante puisque
savannah sfu g8 suivi du mat
ou cram mixte il met sa tour on peut se
le demander mais réfléchi à tout ça
le problème c'est qu'il peut pas trop
faire match marche arrière g il faut
qu'il fasse attention parce que s'il va
trop loin là encore noir et qui est que
ça n'attaque pas ce pas
non mais d'un côté évidemment si vous ça
c'est qu'il estime que c'est bon
pièce les pièces blanches sont quand
même belle le foot des deux îles
fabuleux souffou qui vise le roi va
montrer sa position cochran qui
réfléchit le four b2
quand même est énorme voilà ils
contrôlent montrant la démone peut-être
loin puisqu'il va jusqu'au roi il va
jusqu'au renoir il maintient le renoir à
en respect le groupe olin pour kasparov
ce qu'il a plus de coup de gueule noire
depuis un bout de temps donc il ne peut
pas lutter sur les cases noires il va
falloir problème mettre ses pions sur
cases noires un plan de défense pour lui
c'est de jouer avec m6 5006 affaibli les
cases blanches et e5 est de ramener son
fief 6 tout de suite acheté un très loin
mais je comprends bien je comprends bien
c'était il ya beaucoup de pièces
blanches aussi à l'attack mais il ya des
classements à la défense steffan il faut
pas non plus les oublier ouais mais le
fossé vite pour l'instant ils défendent
caudal des femmes que tu chies le fou
ces huit que tu chies
cut
c'est bien on se demande jusqu'où
chronique a été préparée dans cette
partie l'homme se trouvait toujours
préparés c'est très possible qu'ils
souhaitent ils connaissent encore très
bien ce qui est en train de se passer
ouais mais qui se rappelle toutes les
variantes
c'est possible on lui demandera la
conférence de presse pour voir si ça
énerve kasparov de toute façon chronique
vous dire de façon après des 4 les noirs
sont morts j'ai tout analysé après des
quatre les noirs sont foutus disons le
calmement il n'a aucune chance après des
cas heureusement qu'il me joue aux 4
vérités sport oui il est mal préparée
dans les ouvertures et pas de choisir la
premier mauvais coup à toi un mauvais
premier cours par semaine ça va faire
plaisir à notre ami claude de wagner qui
connaît les lois qu'un fan de kramnik
qui m'a toujours dit que le coût des
quatre étaient beaucoup plus forts que
le coup et quatre à son avis
qui doit jubiler actuellement oui ça
c'est un petit peu des théories comment
dire deux vendeurs de tapis c'est pas
mais ça va faux débat c'est un débat qui
n'a pas de sens si c'est une question de
style à part peut-être pour des joueurs
du top niveau mondial mais enfin je
pense que en dessous de 2800 points elo
on n'a pas vraiment d'éléments de
réponse ne serait-ce que des ébauches
d'éléments possible d'envisager des
éventuelles solutions la chronique qui a
l'habitude comme ça de se coincer les
oreilles cramique incroyable impression
qui met encore une fois sur kasparov
frechaut n'annonce pas mais rappelons
quand même c'était fermé l'enjeu de
cette de cette partie comme elle a nommé
lui dit il est terrible je les gagne
c'est fini c'est fini crasé fini
chronique et je suis un tour du monde
c'est sûr est donc quasi doit il va
comme il passait des trucs bizarres à la
gagne le match est virtuellement de
terminer alors que s'ils perdent le
match est complètement relancé
ah ouais non mais oui oui oui
donc j'ai dit non mais la famille que se
pose même pas la question actuellement
la façon il est en fondant la partie il
est en train dans la ville de phan thi
signe dans le genre non mais c'est qu'il
est mieux il surveiller c'est ce que ça
voulait dire à peu près cette tête là ça
veut dire ah bah tiens
éventuellement il pourrait tenir ici je
vais chercher autre chose
oui là il tient ici un peu là il fait
nul vraiment
il doit penser à des choses bizarres
vladimir kramnik en ce moment et c'est
second temps ils doivent doivent être
dans un état
surprenant aussi dans la noter que
l'équipe doit fatigué l'équipe cramique
elle doit fatigué l'équipe kasparov ont
peu plus depuis longtemps mais l'éthique
en équipe elle aussi doit commencer à
voir des pointes des trous et pointe de
fatigue après -selon un match c'est très
long c'est pas comme en foot c'est à
dire pas 90 minutes ça dure un mois
pas du tout la même chose
pression l'impression que mes chroniques
selon kasparov et la pression monte en
est loin avec ça y est chronique en
dessous de leurs seins va essayer la 52e
minute en minute d'avant d'ios 58 contre
36 et kasparov c'est beaucoup quand même
ah ouais
si cassy kramnik gagne cette partie le
match est fini
à noter qu on l ouvrir on en avait déjà
parlé mais granik a beaucoup changé ces
derniers temps c'est que il est beaucoup
plus sportif
il ne fume plus s'est coupé les cheveux
il est mieux dans sa tête de l'animal
travail itt
alors j'en profite pour de la dotant de
l'infection chronique pour vous dire si
vous écoutez ce match là il va peut-être
jouer là n'ont pas hésité si vous tes ce
match sur la version française et bien
si vous avez des remarques à faire sur
l'interface sur quoi que ce soit
concernant canal web ou leur
transmission mais n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer des mails on en reçoit
maintenant tous les jours de toutes
sortes des gens qui demandent des
conseils pour mieux voir la vidéo ou
pour pour faire des remarques sur les
commentaires agréable ou pas d'ailleurs
il ya un peu de tout oui oui un peu tout
il ya des gens qui apprécient beaucoup
d'autres moins mais en tout cas
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer nos
commentaires on essaie d'en tenir compte
continuez à nous envoyer des emails et
on essaie d'y répondre
peux pas répondre à tous on a beaucoup
trop pour ça alors la tourasse 4h quatre
tours ascani là qu'il a tout vu a joué
tour h4 il a tout vu là il se lance
complètement
il se lance en gros on veut nous isoler
vite s'en va là c'est le match là c'est
joubert compliqué ce n'est pas un succès
hyper complexe g est un réflexe kramnik
attaque à fond le roi de kasparov toile
car il a décidé qu'il fallait provoquer
ce coup f 7 6 la question fait un peu
probable il veut jouer bref cfcm qui
sera possible bref ce n était pas on ne
rappellera jamais assez les call you
sign tout de suite non ma cave de 5 mai
fu g6 bref plus de 4 noir c'est fini oui
plus que ya aussi tour pour un 6 1
litres avec d'empruntis quand même ah
oui au moins jusqu'en mairie avec une
belle boucherie
ouais c'est vrai ainsi tu m'en rends
maintenant ici il va jouer m6 kasparov
toute façon faut qu'ils tiennent un
procès 15 noir il affaiblit les cases
blanches et oui bah oui c'est ça que
j'aime bien dans la peur de ça c'est de
la magie de la paire de fouet granit l'a
dit voilà une fois ce que j'aime bien
qu'amateur de foot c'est quand il y en a
un qui est mauvais et pas loin et il est
très fort
ouais mais là ils sont tous les deux
bons nice que le démon même injouable si
ce fait il peut situer le foot
recasement à 6 5 mais non mais sur m6 il
ya eu 4 e mail wallach rami qui va jouer
autour d un tour bien autour vous
n'entendez c'est beaucoup mieux qu'en
plaine raison parce que là la huitième
rejet des noirs elle n'est pas si forte
que ça mais ils sortent des tours sont
pas liées surtout rennes on peut
envisager de 5 quand même stéphane des
fous et 6
c'est le plan alors on va montrer on va
montrer secours f6 quand m6 qui va
prendre le jeu par kasparov
l'idée m'ont évidemment c'est de fermer
les diagonales du four b2 oui parce que
la menace tout reprend ainsi ses fortes
voilà non il se coupe à l'autre club m6
que kaspar n'ont qu'à les 6 et
positionnelle s'est pas positionné
enfin ils peuvent jouer on n'y croit pas
trop puisque s'enquérir des saints qui
est quand même bien placé
oui puis il faut contre la casse de cinq
ou six as et positionnelle puisqu'il
veut jouer au 6 e 5 et sortir sont fous
ces mythes sur une classe naturelle à
cazaux 6 ouais alors ici l'inconvénient
stéphane qu'est ce que ça peut être
et donc on se le demande eh bien
peut-être tout simplement alors tour des
hommes qu'est ce qui se passe autour d
un 5e quatre ans qu'on peut pas jouer le
coup 4 tout de suite non mais le 4 il ya
un roi prend fonds propres en fout c'est
chaud on apprend tout si chaud mais bon
on va pas trop repris depuis après 1,4
si le cavaly bouge il faut jouer simple
sinon oui c'est ça c'était l'idée alors
cavaliers non mais attends maintenant
mais on prend le roy on prend le fou là
bas c'est pas l'air bon on fout ça a pas
l'air très bon et loi c'est à palabres
pas l'air bon t'as pas l'air bon pas 2 4
par contre qu'un visage a peut-être ses
cavaliers des quatre noms
- qui est des quatre tours c'est un tour
c'est un tour siens d'abord voilà m-66
sillage mais peut-être tour c'est un
abord parce qu est-ce qui s'il oblige
kasparov a joué aussi ce qu'est ce
qu'elle peut être l'idée entre
l'ordinateur donc toujours avantage noir
très difficile à comprendre est en train
de se tasser dans cette partie kramnik
nova risque de ceux de s'embourber est
loin c'est le risque c'est le risque
parce que si les noirs défendent neil
cotty casper vous vite parce qu'il a pas
trop le choix
c'est pas parce qu'il est sûr de lui si
alors attention je viens de voir des
variantes très complexe très
intéressante
je vais prendre un petit moment pour
quelle tristesse va pas accabler b3
keller de gagner du temps j'envisageais
un peu le couteau mg6 des femmes d'alger
si menaçant aux 4 millions d'âmes 8 et
moi allons dame habite ça ne crois pas
justement à cause de tour prend 1,6
quand même c'est beaucoup de contrats
bon il ya beaucoup de coups ouais j'ai
pas ça pas les relances après je sais
pas peut-être
très intéressant très intéressant ces
choix peut-être que quand même il va
bouger son fourrage cette non mais on a
quand même envie de faire jouer la
turquie qui joue pas la loi
pourquoi j'aurais patoureaux c1 et en
cas de d'après-tour c4 pour amener une
tourelle attaque avec l'opportunité
sacrifier une tour peut-être oui alors
là justement alors qu elle s est comment
c'est compliqué oui si salah extrêmement
complexe ça a l'air compliqué chronique
cathy vu qu at il vu là quand même
venant mais est-ce qu'ils soient et le
risque et doit ses propres eaux peut
s'emballer écran qu on peut savoir les
craintes des fans stéphane variante
maria antentas les variants variante
d'en faire bon alors évidemment ça ne va
pas marcher c'est une variante à la un
peu à la nicolas giffard ouais c'était
une très bonne variante il ne marche pas
forcément alors de 5 séances est
envisagée oui alors c'est un peu
abracadabrant mais ouais mais bon on va
loin de le regarder waverly quoi c'était
trop bizarre ça marche pas bon je vais
quand même essayer cavaler points 5
je sais pas dans quel sens commencé
n'ont peut-être pas papa comme ça
peut-être avec le coup tout repensé et
cinq taupes racing
le match qui allait prendre 5 cela
menace qu'obliger sites en france et 5
d'un pont ouais a mis sa menace mata too
late manche termine 3e 5 sa menace des
maths
non là ça menace m'attends à vii ouais
il sut rassemblement au front faut aussi
ce et ont franchi quand même oui et oui
surtout on prend un match surtout en
coin il va le voir on valoir tout de
suite surtout on prend un tour là faut
prendre cinq échecs
voilà le terme duquel ils vous diront à
6 et on le prend et la foux principe six
matches six échecs et mat
donc ça serait terminée ça c'est le rêve
et après tourcoing 6 on a des belles
perspectives non
on menace peut-être des fous j'ai dit
des choses comme ça ouais je pense par
un ca non mais l'ordinateur gratuite
évidemment
ouais non non ça marche ça mais c'est
une des idées pour mettre toutes les
pièces à l'attack c'est pas ton c1 2 5i
c'est l'ordinateur propose faut y croire
avec elle quand même public plus sensée
il faut oui c'est mieux parce que le
foot joue plus sur la diagonale et loi
il a affaibli les cases blanches
ouais on joue x 3 assez logique sa
logique mais elle doit ce retour c'est
est ce que j'aurai pas plutôt cavaliers
b3 weeds noms n'ont peut-être pas qui a
et b 3 ici mais ça c'est pas une belle
case cela est même temps c'est pas une
trace de ces chrétiens de temps oui mais
sans père aussi parce que le cavalier
est en prison maintenant il ya des
menaces de foot pro 26 tu vois mon sens
un jouet pour ses quatre tours sekkat
autour d un beau matin de tour 6 4 avec
l'idée tour g4 qu'à l'heure de faire un
camp même très mal non non ça c'est pas
très mal maintenant au tour de msi
pourquoi pas tenter un coup aux
multiples menaces
alors on va donc 5 admettons leurs cinq
tours sénat c'est 2,5 à leur logique bon
au 5 août des signes se ferait à dire
sur scène qu on va en faire mention du 6
9 et 6 alors plus embêtant et loire à
cause de cavale et des quatre ou cinq
des six hommes et six cas les d4 attaque
la classe c 6 c'est quand même assez
embêtant ça al'air embêtant
ouais complexe donc en fait voilà la
position actuelle
vous l'avez sur votre un plaid à droite
c'est celle là aussi sur la vidéo et
granby qu'on attend le coup de tours f1
en c1 qui amène la dernière pièce en jeu
qu'elle a besoin on attend ouais à noter
qu'on commence un peu à paniquer pour
chroniquer stéphane puisqu'ils ont
fléchi beaucoup ah oui 52 minutes
une action que 20 minutes d'avancé la
pendule ici 52 minutes restant prendre
33 kasparov pour jouer d'un coup un coup
à jouer pour les dents cramique à peu
près dans les temps toujours sauf s'il
réfléchit un quart d'heure là ça va ça
va devenir chaud mais kasparov lui ai
quand même car en dessous mais disons
que c'est quand même pas se tromper d'un
seul en attaque c'est une question plus
simple à jouer pour les noirs stephano
oui c'est ça voilà ce que en défense en
général n'y a que quelques coups qui
tienne oui ok blanc doivent chercher
très loin cravoisier attaque
est-ce que kramnik ne se serait pas
emballé ces données parti c'est le
risque
mais là ça serait une partie aussi de 6
g rippert ce qui est improbable il
aurait perdu tout seul
4 offre une fois de plus rien montré oui
c'est vrai il a juste fallu pour cela
sur calais b 3 tout simplement fou prend
f6 non puisque le flash est en faillite
d'après stéphane ah oui c'est vrai mais
surtout ça qui avait trois tours bien
c'est très bien avec amiens b 3 est mal
placée ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai
pour propose aussi un devoir aussi on va
jouer live à jouer il va jouer là il va
jouer
déjà moi je pense là il avait dit c'est
qu'il est sûr de son coup
pascal en bas toute façon tour c1 c'est
à peu près force est dans cette position
stéphane je vois pas ce qui peut nous
trouver d'autres autour des 1 aussi
possible d'en tourner à on n'avait pas
mentionné un problème non quel problème
en moins c'est possible au centre d un
c'est pas mal parce que parce que c'est
possible c'est vrai c'est pas mal et
pourquoi et bien parce que c'est
possible
quelle pension des tensions assez
horriblement chaud super chaud c'est
horriblement chaud il ya du sacrifice de
pièces dans les reins ouais on voit pas
pour l'instant on arrive à le faire
marcher vraiment le général on les voit
jamais les sacrifices de pièces genre
cavagnoud 5 un coup comme ça ah oui
tiens d'ios 5
on va le mentionner parce que c'est joli
mais non à sa peur tout de suite on va
pas mentionné tour 6-1 alors d'être le
couvoir fous ces deux éventuellement
d'alors fous ces deux c'est une
proposition d'ordinateur on s'appelle
retrait est logique
un tour sert il faut jeter aux chiens
est-ce que cramique n'est pas en train
de s'embourber dans la taxe sur le roi
parce que le problème si ça passe pas
les normes plus en plus aller à dame
ils vont jouer à 5 très vite après nom
créé un pion passé peut-être mais
oui hélas non mais c'est à dire que les
coûts de kasparov là les coupes casse
parfait en train de faire vont très bien
dans le plan ils bloquent le fou blanc
de cases noires il n'a pas le choix
pourquoi et bien parce que lui il a un
fou noir de cases blanches lui permet
donc de contre l'éclatement shayk s'en
fout si les pays contrôlent les cases
noires c'est homogène
ces compagnies feu kramnik ne sais pas
mais la dernière fois qu'on a vu crâne
est dans une situation qui avait la
délicate
eh bien il nous a sorti quelque chose
d'inattendu impôts ni loi et loyaux
ah oui non mais ça marche pas comme ces
tours c'est un le coup c'était enfin
tous les jouets de 4 et au 5 les samedis
de 4,5 mais ça permet très vite doit
prendre fin en france où un tour 6-1
alors d'autres le coup mais mais mais
mais un texte ramène toi quand même
tenir compte de certaines menaces
par exemple le coût qui n'est pas une
menace pour l'instant mais ça serait g7
g5 qui à chaque fois 7 avec la dame
bon malheureusement il ya des recours en
justice pour l'instant mais g league
doit tenir compte de ce genre de
possibilités
j'essaie de g5 dans deux jours ça marche
et donc pas acheter magna tout proche de
la nature
non là est peut-être le couffo à 3 et
plus près si loin maintenant que les 15
mars ont pris tout de suite changé la
diagonale du fou pour qu'il travaille tu
vois on aime mieux 80 tours qu'un four
stéphanois et en plus pour l'instant le
fouillis donne quand même eu à des
combinaisons parce que disent ils
empêchaient 5e ça c'est important parce
qu'il parce qu'elle s'attaque en mai
porsche est en même temps la torah chien
de poche non non non ça menace rien du
tout et 5 ont foré fuji 6e
tranquillement
suivi de cavaliers ou 5 oui
ouais style
je pense qu'ils veulent avec une petite
variante tiens on va montrer imaginant
fou à 3 tu vas rencontrer les attentes à
la fois trois fois trois passes alors
hier x 3 x 3 j'aime parce qu'on est
d'accord mais f 16 f cell lampe f5
non mais sinon non mais je manque la
variante 9,5 c'est pas bon ça attaque le
fourrage cet ol pouget 6 oui dame f6
cristaux et que ça mais il ya le cas
laissé cinq ans président assad mêmes
s'attaquent le fou bon c'est plus hélas
tout reproche 6 échec surprenant qui ne
marche pas c'est sûr tout de suite je ne
mange pas c'est une belle idée
l'idée ce cas là on revient b2i la dame
écroués dans b2 mais hier il suffit à
jouer qui a laissé 3 en 1 et donc ça ne
marche pas mais bon c'était bien tenté
non il ya beaucoup de talent beaucoup de
talent mais si ça passe pas
rami qui l'option de moins oui non mais
là tu as part of 10 ans elle va changer
de surnom ça va pas être le cas ce prof
je voulais le roc natation si les spurs
en soirée comme ça en plus
eh bien il peut gagner la partie et
comme kramnik réfléchi et bien on n'est
pas trop confiants pour lui la sas est
purement psychologique
c'est évidemment purement psychologique
en chronique et bien autant et qui joue
vite on pense qu'il est mieux quand il
réfléchit on pense qu'il est moins bien
mais en fait pas du tout grave ni qui
est toujours probablement un petit peu
mieux
bon ça sans saveur clair que s'il veut
ça s'écrit pas parce qu'il a une
expérience énorme sur ce type de
position qui l'a rentrer là dedans c'est
parce que
il ya des trucs non il veut jouer pour
ces jeux torcéen tranquillement et puis
après b si ça chauffe eau à 3 il va
récupérer son pion c5 et puis ils vont
faire nul ça c'est dans le pire des cas
pourtant réunis autour des 1 et loi
tendant à montrer la variante autour des
1 et je ne vois pas ce côté avec ce qu
autour d un jeune à méditer c'est de
supprimer deux cavaliers dessaivre de
qualité c'est un protégé si ce que tu
joues je joue par exemple aux cinq ou
six adhérents
elle a peut-être maintenant et bien d'un
g si ces lois
à ce moment-là d'objets 6 bon ok je ne
vois toujours pas l'idée donc c'était
faux et 6,6 et alors là
tout reprend 1,6 alors je ne vois
toujours pas l'idée donc je prends la
tour et ça va pas et rien alors retirer
les noms mais je voulais je voulais
qu'on va les prendre 5 mais il
yad'autres en https pour l'instant que
les dires d'un proche est nommé la
normale les noirs même beaucoup de
possibilités défensives wayne rosso
ça va pas sans espérer noir s'en sortent
les blancs en souffriront non mais si
les noirs se développe est mal passé et
je vois pas comment les blancs d'oeufs
dans le péché même si kramnik et rentrer
là dedans il a forcément envisagé s'il
s'est pas emballé non je pense qua non
c'est pas le genre s'est adjointe de la
maison
normalement il a assuré il est gras mi
cuit au four et qu'il mène de deux du
maine de deux points non une chronique
n'est pas euphorique
il est très timide et très secret niveau
fort et qu'il est bien assis dans son
grand fauteuil je sais pas je l'aï
entendu quand même parce que le scra
nick fury qui mène 2 0
il a une attaque une position à grosse
valeur ajoutée d'attac t'espero réfléchi
comme info il ya du public
ils jouent pour le spectacle il dit
voilà maintenant je vais faire une
miniature encore une fois il s'emballe
kasparov tranquille prendre le pion et
ensuite le pousse à dame
quand on écrit je viens dehors des
offres j'ai eu six fois les blancs
jusqu'à maintenant
j'étais gagnant quatre fois j'en ai
gagné deux j'ai fait nul facile donc
d'âge ou non mais il n'a pas pu la jouer
sans calculer bah non c'est clair non
mais ici dans ma vie n'a pas de problème
ont récité un échange généralisé ans et
5 très logiquement on est peut-être tout
simplement les north on trouve avec un
endroit complètement faibles tout
simplement en finale même en finale non
c'est bhl c'est difficile parce que
les pions de celle des caisses noires il
faut maintenir les cases blanches c'est
pour ça que ce sport fait pas jouer le
système pour il était surpris par tour
h4 kasparov c'est un coût qu'il
n'attendait pas quand même temps dans
chroniques a dû réfléchir à ce coup et 6
qu'est-ce qui calcule en vidant
superforme travail est qu'il a sûrement
vu quelque chose malheur je ne sais pas
ce qu'il a vu parce qu'alors nous on ne
pourrait pas gagner contre kasparov sa
poigne et ça c'est pas une référence
qu'est ce qui se passe rien et 43
minutes pour kramnik zaïre il rejoint
kasparov autant il reste 33 minutes à
kasparov mais 43 min pour kramnik c'est
plus difficile de trouver des coudes
attaque que de défense ça c'est connu
non mais l'attaqué n'a pas l'air de
passer travail a pas de trucs la langue
ne sais pas du tout si c'est crucial ne
faut pas que comme il se trompe puisque
mon erreur elle est noire prendra le
dessus avec leur plan de plus il se
passe là
c'est des possibilités
pour l'heure très bonnes notes en
engageant président
quand je pense qu'il va falloir ramener
le foot g7 9h 7 ans et deux non pas en
ses deux parents c'est pourquoi ça
semble un clone de tours non mais tour d
un an et on mène un autre tour sur la
colonne des non j'ai pas il ya beaucoup
de possibilités défensives pour garry
kasparov ça c'est certain
vingt deux côtés d'un côté elles sont
rois est faible ça c'est sûr c'est sûr
que son roi est faible il en un courant
d'air maintenant on va pas trop comment
les plantes peuvent progresser dans l'
attaque pourrait arriver un col et le
cavalier engis issélois voilà un plan
peut-être et pour ça il faut bouger la
tour 2 h théâtre
alors peut-être voile mais voilà donc
quand même qu'une idée tour h5 non
pourquoi
non mais vous proposons plutôt bien mais
tu auras chèque et loi menace peut-être
eu ce que quatre dans cette femme
variantes pour attaquer le calice et 5
pourquoi pas tous ces clubs plutôt non
mais ces quatre ans reviendra c4 et oui
maintenant que l'inde a provoqué f6 un
oui peut-être l'idée que kelly peut
venir en chine note à oui voilà en gc
oui oui peut-être voilà vous ici
possible aussi dans ces quatre c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal ça menace
éventuellement fou à trois tout être sa
menace vient encore de kiabi hkd
oui parce que collet h4 il va où le roi
là avaient droit parce que le roi il
peut pas bouger on ne peut pas empêcher
qu'un léger six échecs la falloir sur
câble et j'ai six échecs prend dans le
fou et se mettre dans une découverte
pays
alors que faire là surtout en c4
je vois pas de solution pour par les
cavaliers h41 fait cranie doit hésiter
entre tour ses quatre tours h5 votre
tour s'éclater tour cn possible hosni
tous ces cas très piètre mieux
effectivement il a provoqué f6
affaiblissement et maintenant il revient
c4 voilà voilà voilà peut-être à
peut-être l'idée est ce qu'on peut jouer
aux 5 avec les noirs n'ont que ça chez
les soins on va voir on va voir mais
justement allez on va voir une variante
le 5 il a eu cinq là les blancs jour et
à la tension
on va réfléchir dans un premier temps
alors il ya qu'amélie h4 qui est
possible effectivement ça il faut le
full envisagée il faut à 3 qui est
possible aussi c'est un deuxième plan
puisque on a dit que le fonds était mort
en dédommageant ouais donc le remettre à
3 c'est pas mal d'ailleurs par exemple
oui je pense que ce soit 3 c'est bien
après des six qui est fort c'est
maintenant caillage 4 non mais qu'est ce
qui se passe au cafouillage cas très
loin et pourquoi pas tour sert ici non
mes cavaliers h4 menaces auxquelles j'ai
si ce fait est que gagne la dame tuer
des chiens que font les noirs faut
bouger de la dha et epa de maths non
priori n'y a pas de maths mais bon il ya
des découvertes dans tous les sens par
exemple on peut envisager tout de suite
une solution mauvaise pour les morts
y a pas de risque à ce peut-être non
mais là les blancs c'est vrai ne risque
rien ils rigolerait se sent que c'est un
peu trop on sent que c'est un peu trop
pour ces quatre c'est pas mal pour ça
c'est pas mal non il tandis que rien de
grave ne risque rien aucun doute
valériscle rien il lui reste 39 minutes
mais c'est pas parce qu'il réfléchit que
contre 33 kasparov pour jouer un coup
ils boivent un coup pas facile les
partis maintenant c'est pas le nombre de
coups qui jouent et loi c'est carrément
il ya du ko
très vite un autant la partie 4 et 6 on
a eu droit à plus de 60 coups ce qui est
beaucoup
autant là depuis quelques parties c'est
chaud aussi mais ça se joue en vert ou
trente coups quoi c'est c'est le ko
d'entrée
quelles parties de cramique quelle
attaque quelle attaque
en tout cas si j 6 g league à newcastle
qu'il va être fou oui ça c'est ça c'est
sûr mais trouve même en cas de nul c'est
pas mal pour chroniques rappelons
qu'oddo quand même en une dominent le
match
il peut donc faire nul comme agent
technique mais là ils jouent ce sport il
joue avec panache comme l'a sûrement
joué sa tour h4 ou alors l'autre il va
jouer nous coûte pourquoi donc on va
devoir ouais c'est là que le crâne et
joue à deux points d'un coup il n'a pas
d'option datant du nom de tour en l'air
des coups de tours a l'air fort à la
grèce décidé il joue pas il arrive à la
fois mon là de toute évidence les
joueurs vont accélérer mais la position
est vraiment extrêmement intéressante
c'est dommage que les joueurs soient
obligés de la jouer rapidement
tu peux faire des fautes la doyenne
nalco 10 y réfléchit c'est que c'est
très complexe a noté stéphane que dans
le jeu rapide pour l'instant dans ce
qu'on appelle les trikes note c'est que
kasparov qui joue mieux
oui c'est vrai mais jouer en défense
aussi joué en défense et encore une fois
en défense ces bidules soit ça passe
soit ça casse coin on n'a pas le choix
on va y aller quand il s'agit de trouver
le seul coup garry kasparov est une
véritable machine voilà parce que je
vais attaquer en général on a le choix
entre trois ou quatre coups et c'est
moins simple
réflecteurs de cravic lui reste 37
minutes
akram nique pour jouer vingt coups que
va-t-il jouer à quoi petit bien
réfléchir chronique pour ses quatre
peut-être tour c1
thorstein tu penses pas tu aimes pas
trop ancien bah c'est pas une très belle
très simple deux côtés moi j'aime bien
un coup de côté saliba la casaque 4 et
en même temps si tu veux ça fait
pression un petit peu sur les caves à
lille un nom lui chez pour h 4 c'est
bien par exemple après au sein il ya des
fous g4 qui arrive
non mais cavalia jetables tout de suite
pour chien qui a aussi des neuf c1 en
2007 non non mais pourquoi ne pas mettre
la tour 6 4
ça fait une menace du plateau ont acheté
à aucune variante hall est utile alors
quand ces quatre elle est utile sans
citer parce qu'on peut toujours si si
mais sur fait c'est utile parce que v il
ya des trucs coin
3-5 ça libère et ça peut me lasser tout
reprendre cavaliers peut-être non je
suis pas là c'est du délire je m'emballe
un peu la leur la tour tourne au roi
rachat des pratiques non il va jouer
soit 7,4 toiture c4 soit tour c'est un
voile a forcé un des analyses diagonale
c'est ça pour l'instant restée collée
tour c'est un autre c4 et chroniques
comme il a tendance à nous écouter
c'est vrai et bien besoin de ses deux
coups oui d'ailleurs oui
un très probable chronique va jouer un
jour ou l'autre
fabien qui joue un coup la réflexion
qu'il acquit la combine y réfléchit la
presse que 40 minutes de réflexion non
au moins trente minutes de réflexion
presque non le moment est crucial
le moment est crucial il va rester à peu
près trente trois minutes aux deux
joueurs pour jouer vingt coups ce qui
est très peu c'est moitié moins du temps
moyen moitié moins que le temps moyen
une minute trente de moyenne par coup au
lieu de trois minutes mais le moment est
crucial va passer sous kasparov à la
pendule na waie non mais ça il est en
train de le rattraper il a 34 minutes
contre 33 c chronique je vous parle il
va passer sous kasparov
ce qui n'est jamais agréable mais si
j'avais très agréable c'est un peu
saute-mouton quoi oui oui tout à fait
comme à l'école mon crâne ni que tu
joues la has et à leur attention parce
que l'it ou les coûts vont fuser
maintenant maladie oui ils menacent le
choix ils vont accélérer nos notes de
jouer très vite là parce que la série
s'est terminée il ne reste plus que 30
minutes pour jouer d'un coup donc ils
vont là on a droit on a eu droit debout
devant nous le temps de réflexion mais
là c'est terminé
il y avait un coup à jouer en demi heure
ça va jouer très vite c'est obligé ah
j'ai mal au ventre
c'est horrible la pression à la tension
c'est horrible c'est le moment critique
et voilà ça y est égalité autant égalité
août un très beau plan là de yannick et
nick très directif robot yannick on le
salue un très beau point de chronique
juste au moment où les joueurs sont à
égalité au temps
or à biarritz alors que la flore
peut-être penser un non non non non non
pas du tout puisque ça a déjà été fait
ah oui mais oui oui c'est passé à
l'envers bon bref donc là ces phrases
mystérieuses owen ne vous concerne pas
malheureusement
mais vous pouvez les interpréter comme
vous voulez si la magie du commentaire
sous cape est bon alors
il faut
c'est chaud ça peut-être le coup du
match granic il va jouer le coup dames 1
elle est chronique achève le fini 9
l'asie vient faire un christophe 4 hir
et fichiers de quatre crans montana
enquête cela rend proches sont là dix
ans après foule puis on prend on apprend
3 bougez
puis on prend aussi ce fou prend avec un
point de plus avec comme si en plus et
une poubelle pour ramener finale elle
gémit le concept de poubelles alors bon
vladimir l'a1
allez allez je vous le ton coup la tour
c est au tour c4 allait a priori on
parie pour à l'horaire moi je ne sache
rien
il ya une bonne proposition qui donna
année c'est le coup stéphane d'abord
et oui tour d un coup autour des 1 donc
nouvelles possibilités peut-être pour
chronique autour des 1 dans ce n'est pas
là c'est la tombe des mains est possible
aussi il faut mettre plein soccram ni
parce qu'il va jouer là bas je pense que
il va penser à jouer il faut qu'on le
voit de loin alain faucon broadway voilà
là il va forcément je veux jouer de ton
tort puisqu'il ne reste plus que 31
minutes
il y aura 20 coups à jouer donc s'il
réfléchit trop là il va perdre en temps
un et ça ce n'est pas bon non c'est pas
bon c'est pas bon à noter que il servait
à karpov uniquement nos perdante un
championnat du monde
ça lui arrive régulièrement à karpov de
perdre autant on a un championnat du
monde ça lui arrivait mais je pense
qu'il va être perdant la position il
était perdant la position mais cela
arrive une fois c'est très rare et un
instinct de survie chez karpov
il permet de beaucoup de courant très
peu de temps ouais quand la pendule
d'ajouter qu'il est tombé quand ce
n'était pas une produits électroniques à
tes fans sont maintenant on ne tombe
plus répandue électronique le coup qui
vaut ça vaut combien ce coup là si 5000
$ ca ca vaut le titre de champion du
monde petit échantillon des moines et
six cent mille dollars
cette partie vous si 5000 $ si kramnik
la gagne plus le titre de champion du
monde c'est quand même pas mal ça vous
chers le coup ça vaut le coup de
réfléchir mais attention parce qu'il ya
d'autres coups à jouer derrière
il va le mettre trente minutes kramnik
pression qu il réfléchit il a dû faire
le tour déjà un sac et bien aux échecs
c'est qu'on n'a jamais fait le tour il
ya toujours des nouvelles possibilités
arrive de nouvelles idées qui
jaillissent est allé vladimir ça fait
combien de temps qu'il réfléchit
chronicles bientôt quarante minutes
peut-être même plus fo a trois journées
grosse réflexion dans notre jeu x 3
kramnik le coup complètement inattendu
bon il va vers une tour à bâle iii
serait pas illogique puisque le foot a
pas actuellement sur un mur oui nommé la
torah grâce à facetime un détourage 4
aussi elle tape sur un néant la wii
c'est vrai nom toutes les pièces
secrètes sur nenon il a donc comme le
coup surprenant eloi g4 oui non non je
crois pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
non mais j 4 j c'est une menace g5
bon alors envisageons pour faire plaisir
à stéphane le coup j'ai dejé 4 alors que
nous avons de la visite
merci
ces remarques de nantes réalisateur qui
sait pas calculer qui s'inquiètent donc
d'aider de l'argent que m comment
toucher les champions il remarque que
l'argent sur un compte bloqué enfin non
il manque effectivement si 5000 $ c'est
pour le perdant est le vainqueur gagne
deux fois plus donc aux millions 2 donc
ça veut dire que le vainqueur gagne bien
si 5000 $ de plus que le perdant
donc ça veut dire que la partie vaut
bien si 5000 $ puisque le perdant
ça fait 7 en valeur relative à leurs
nombreux fans on va quand même regarder
beaucoup magique parce que là il faut il
faut le dire c'est du jamais vu chez pas
je cherche quand même le coup ce serait
le coût qui tue mais bon les 4 rbds
malheureusement [ __ ] à ossun le 5 mai
g5 du g5 je prends avec quoi avec
l'option lequel suis là et bien là
cavalier prendre 5 et doit tout de suite
un menace cahier g6 échec car la dame
ah oui ayé vie ben oui ah oui oui j'ai
appris je joue tout reprend ainsi son
clan allez c'est pas pareil c'est mieux
c'est pas pareil et bien là en fout g8
il n'y a pas de maths c'est une
certitude et bien et loi je joue le coup
maintenant
et surtout rachat qui a coûté 4 sert de
la table ouais
ça marche pas ça alors je sais pas je
cherche ce qu'on peut trouver cramique
quoi j'écarte c'était une belle
tentative tentative très intéressant
tentative de fou mais bon des diligences
énoncé c'était c'était très très
intéressant malheureusement il va devoir
se résigner à juin des coupes alors il
reste 27 minutes kramnik c'est terrible
c'est terrible
33 kasparov et de ton avis de la cre il
est peut-être un moment où ils tournent
à vide
quel match quel match c'est de la folie
ici à londres
riverside studio cram knicks a fait 45
minutes qui réfléchit une position qui
très très prometteuse plein de
possibilités dans les grosses positions
d'attac et messi gagne la partie ici qui
gagne le match
alors ils cherchent toutes les solutions
mais attention parce que s'il perd et
bien le match est complètement relancé
le classement fort à deux fois les
blancs quand kraft peut perdre
oui oui ici là maintenant il s'est mis
en position où il peut perdre il a pris
des risques ramener qu'il a pris
d'énormes risques alors c'est
effectivement ce résultat de la partie
qu'on dira si c'est bien ou pas un peu
comme jugnot la france bulgarie mais
quand même très étonné si quand on avait
mesuré 10 cm de plus ont retenu au génie
alors que là on a crié au scandale fait
c'est pareil pour chronique
qu'est ce qui va faire comme nicklas
alors on a mal pour lui l'un c'est
tension extrême tension extrême ses fans
je vais te masser très très chaud très
très chaud mais qu'est-ce qui va jouer
avec ces péripéties horrible un coût non
mais maintenant je veux un coup la
chronique en train de se mettre tout
seul en zinc note
olalala moins qu'ils aient tout vu ah
oui si les toons stefanski possible
grammy corps et sainte-catherine a tout
vu il a tout vu ça fait une force et
voire même sakai alors que à quoi
réfléchir à munich
non
je vais vous laisser dans ce grand
moment d'émotion pendant quelques
minutes mais évidemment stéphane va
commenter ça avec brio ce pas ça
aaa quality majorité tour c4 ça y est il
a joué le coup qu'on attendait tous sur
la caisse c42 kramnik voilà eh bien tu
joues il y aura réfléchi
presque cinquante minutes chronique pour
jouer ce coup pour ses coûts alors que
kasparov kasparov a l'air de et oui
kasparov a encore demandé l arbitre de
faire une vérification probablement pour
le son
réfléchir à ce coup tours c4 à noter
qu'il reste plus que 25 minutes à
chronique pour jouer 19 coups contre 32
minutes à kasparov et la partie est
extrêmement tendue les blancs ayant une
position très prometteuse et beaucoup d
espace un renoir très affaibli des
menaces dans tous les sens et c'est très
chaud
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe
haïssam leurs icônes risque qu'est-ce
qui se passe eh bien quoi bon quand
notre réalisateur rendu les armes et
nous avons fait intervenir en défense
contre kasparov et arbitres avant de le
voir pour dire qu'il ya ça fait beaucoup
trop de bruit mais quel bruit mais je ne
sais pas justement parce que là donc
nous avons signalé à l'arbitré qu'il n'y
ait pas de bruit oui et l'arbitraire
partie donc a priori pas de problème
enfin très surprenante m ce qui se passe
parce que le son le son mais son
générique le centre yannick aurait été
trop fort non mais je pense que ce que
nous cherchons encore des excuses
werner benz high et cherche encore des
excuses comme il va encore dire qu'il
était gagnant il collection l'empêcher
de jouer ramener 15e tour ses quatre
essais bien joué c'est ce qu'on
attendait à noter que kramnik s'est
jamais plaint du seront donc ramic
anneaux il est cool quand on est très
très heureux très calme incroyable quand
même kasparov qui décidément est prêt à
tout pour se justifier
prêt à tout
kasparov tounzi l'adil arbitre c4 mais
n'a pas compris pourquoi
bon alors donc l'âme ski hyper
inquiétant pour les deux joueurs 1,6 et
1,9 c'est maintenant les savates lanctôt
logique zain 25 minutes à kramnik contre
30 à 40 pour jouer dix neuf coups on est
quasiment dans un semi rapides et loi
est tout à fait vrai aussi que dans les
semi rapides tout peut arriver
laghdaf n'est jamais loin le problème
c'est qui qui risque le plus de faire
une gaffe kramnik ou kasparov balle
assez compliqué c'est difficile à dire
c'est plutôt qu'à munich franchement ce
plutôt chronique qui auraient du mal à
gérer c'est mon attention extrême de
zain hot 100 qui correspond à l avantage
d'être en défense ça c'est quand même un
avantage
est-ce que kasparov a pas joué le coup
acn kehlois dans l'âme le coup qu'on ait
mentionné c'était des 6 des femmes et à
5 alors à 5
parce qu'on crée un pion passer en
veille ont créé une contre chance tout
de suite si on prend et on gagne en
temps pour libérer le fou maintenant bel
donc prendre ça serait la prise en
passant appauvri pendant passants mais
on ne va pas le faire bien sûr le plus
impatients pourront jouer des scènes
qu'il voit tout de suite en plus est il
redescend
les cinq là ce qu'on peut commencer par
envisager kg 10 h théâtre
déjà c'est quand même une des menaces
qui avaient été créés oui menace calais
g61 g62 ouais mais bon ça me laisse pas
grand chose que font les noirs ici et
bien et noir jouer le ku'damm 6-7 9-7
bon mc ça tellement l'idée évidemment
c'est qu'après kg 6 échecs on prend le
faut acheter et il n'y a pas de
découverte intéressante pour le cabinet
cercle qui a dit paul et n'importe où il
fera pas un échec percutant mais la dame
ans et 7 stéphane se met dans le clonage
oui maintenant on peut ramener encore
une tour en action avec torcéen ouais
mais bon il ya un pion passé noir et sur
b 6 et à peu près les landes que je te
disais tout à l'heure où des quatre
décades voilà on récupère le pion tout
simplement
exactement on va récupérer notre pion à
veiller au grain noir a toujours très
fait là c'est ça on aura toujours qui
est g6 dans le vent petit avantage pour
les bleus ont-ils une petit avantage
pour les blancs malgré deux ans ont
passé
ouais ouais malheureuse pour ba oui
puisqu'on aura aussi un pion dessins de
passer ça c'est vrai voilà la position
dans laquelle kasparov réfléchi qu'est
ce qui peut faire on attend b6 parce
qu'il faut a priori blindés ce cavalier
en c5
voilà je suis là je suis hyper tendu
parce que les joueurs sont quand même
engrangé it not c'est vraiment c'est
hyper show hyper chaud
adressez van bree perchaud vont
accélérer en plus ça va être de la folie
et avec un petit peu de chance justement
en plus ils vont réfléchir le poussera
un rythme frénétique mais la crise
porsche réfléchit il ya vingt-huit
minutes maintenant qu'entre 25 minutes à
kramnik c'est ça qui c'est ça qui nous
serait ce qui les motive était cependant
voilà la magie fait sa tête motivé
exceptionnellement nos droits humains
dans ma logique tout peut arriver là
maintenant avec le temps qui reste la
façon même si cramique obtient un petit
avantage il peut faire la guerre tout de
suite d'actes espérant finir oui disons
que son problème et espérance et qu'elle
était sous pression toute la partie
ouais c'est ça psychologiquement c'est
très dur d'en ressortir ouest ans n'a
pas cette capacité
alors qu'un joueur comme boris parce
qu'ils avaient à montauban si la pala
comme s'ils se retirent pas l'impression
pourquoi c'est non mais c'est
l'alternance de passer une position où
on est resserré on est en train de se
défendre comme des fous et après il faut
tout de suite se met à jour une position
d'un style complètement différent il
sait faire ça casse par an c'est le roi
de la contre attaque
non c'est non non non c'est très
particulier le spécialiste de ça cet
espace non de la tête de kasparov là et
c'était d'ailleurs le grand défaut de
bobby fischer stéphane qui n'arrivait
pas à passer d'un type de position un
autre sens justement faire de gaffes des
fautes
cramique à l'air sur lui n'a pas l'air
si sûr que ça à la place d'acheter un
titre un petit coup d'oeil la guitare
offre indique à six a l'air d'être le
coût est là si c'est pas mal ah si c'est
intéressant à 6,1 mais ça non mais c'est
très chaud pour kasparov parce que quand
même quand même c'était pas sur a6 on
peut envisager un coup comme b 6 x 3 bis
si c'est sûr qu'il prendrait si c'est
bien il y aura des combines est qu'elle
combine est base de cavalia est d'abord
ont tous la dame ont sacré filles dans
ses 56 ans vous d'alger 6 chaud chaud
chaud
des variantes d'épargnants des baryons
toujours des variantes
il ya vraiment quand même dire quand
même de l'attak organique atteint
puisque corps mais il ya quand même de
la défense pour gagner c'est super tendu
voilà la gare ils se parlent et qui
sépare les îles c'est par la musique que
kasparov s'est parlé il sait parler tout
seul
qu'est ce qui s'est dit il n'aurait plus
belle s'était dit ça y est j'y suis né
j'y suis je suis plus forte du monde
c'est fini
c'est une possibilité d'autres
possibilités c'est ça y est je le tiens
je reviens dans le match et je vais la
voir
kasparov s'est parlé
bon tension et freine sa se voit
d'ailleurs c'est un des refrains un des
rares moments dans le match mais deux
joueurs sont assis l'un en face de
l'autre
il reste 25 minutes les joueurs en jouer
21 coups en 1h30 chacun chacun il reste
25 minutes à chacun pour jouer 19 coup
quasiment la même somme de coûts ça veut
dire la tension qui est en train de se
passer là évidemment la moindre faute
les joueurs savent jouer très vite une
position gagnante
non pas il faut éviter les fautes mais
si on vous plaît pas de faute mais on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'en faire une
apprennent pas faire 1-1 suite ces abcès
voire plus si beaucoup pour un coût et
il y aura de moins en moins de temps
pour les suivants aux perches aux
perches aux le coup à six a l'air d'être
le bon coup
on est à 6 et très responsable stéphane
très responsable si la presse b65
ramener s'est levé comme unique essai de
la partie
est-ce qu'ils auraient tous vu kramix
est possible peut-être qu'il a tout du
chronique l'année sur a6 ya pas fou à 3
faut être en paix toujours pas si ça
peut sans mélange peut pas jouer mais si
tu agis comme en pâture en bessin voyons
voyons à 6 et loyaux à la vraie position
rapidement à son bail en a six l'idée
c'est que de prendre bissen cas là on
jouerait baissier moi je pense que j'ai
envie de commencer de toute façon pas
recueilli h4 ça c'est un coût qui plaît
j'aime bien mettre le client a ajouté
adham c7
il faut que tu bouges la dame alors soit
on décide france et 7 c'est cette
salaires moins d'un v6 alors demandé si
c'est mieux bon et là on voit qu'il ya
toujours pas de découverte intéressante
annonce est maintenant beaucoup beaucoup
de possibilités pour ses seins moi j'ai
envie de te reprends ce serait un tout
le temps mais bon c'est pas parce qu'on
a envie que c'est bon et au principe
c'est que ça marche pas et p6 a marre
publicis maintenant si tu joues pas b6
avancer c'est pas tout à fait pareil il
faut peut-être joué d'abord des six pour
l onu cavaliers de la défense durant
noir c'est ça je sais pas je calcule
vraiment beaucoup de choses là stéphane
chez les chiites
j'ai du mal à m'y retrouver donc
j'imagine que ça doit être l'enfer pour
les joueurs en tout cas ce qui est sûr
plein de paris à la carte
il déroule la position est extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué les joueurs
d'avoir des choses que au delà de ce que
peut voir l'ordinateur d'ailleurs à win
avait largement largement ça n'a rien à
voir mais là il se passe des trucs ça
n'a vraiment rien à voir intentions en
maintenant la position
23 minutes à kasparov qui repasse sous
kramnik et 58 ans la c1 saute-mouton
auquel on assiste et réchauffe kramix ou
kasparov puisque l'espérance ou
chroniques autant c'est super chaud le
match est en train de se jouer pour le
vent maintenant qui fait la tête
alors il fait non de la tête d'où ils
viennent jeter un oeil à la pendule la
crise par aof
22 minutes il reste à gaspard enfin une
minute park où ça va jouer très vite un
moment donné vous savez dur à suivre
ça va être très dur à suivre
ah ah
oh
et non une variante qui marchent pas
rater rappelé il y en a envie d'un peu
de possibilités non mais c'est vrai
qu'avec les blancs on a envie de tout ça
l'a vraiment trop envie de lever toutes
les pièces et f111 vidéo et toutes les
pièces pour attaquer ce roi mais non
mais ça marche pas donc pas s'emballer
rente qui restait en coulisses et pas
s'emballer faut pas s'emballer
flottement foireuse dans mes fois je me
positionnerai je pense tout simplement
ouais mais le renard sera faible à la
fin positionnelle c'était dans une cité
à des pirates ça va voler ça va voler
cravic aurait tout vu je ne sais pas ce
qu'il a vu dans mes chroniques est parti
il a quitté la table
un espace est surnommé stéphane est ce
que tu te rends compte de ce qui se
passe rami qui a quitté la table à qui
il reste 25 19 25 minutes pour jouer
vingt coups que la position est hyper
compliqué rien qu'en face c'est kasparov
et qui joue pour le titre de champion du
monde + 600 milles de là il est pas là
dominés dans sa loge il voit l'échiquier
ils ont un sens il est dans sa loge bon
c'est bon c'est parce qu'il fait une
tête les pipis s'habille faire pipi
c'est possible c'est possible c'est
possible alors avant l'orage kramnik
surveiller donc aller faire pipi
kasparov qui fait l'écho des non de la
tête
et qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent bien voire
pas bon c'est pas bon c'est pas du tout
ce qu'est ce qu'ils en train de voir cet
excellent stéphane sais que tu as part
of a porno mais non non non non il la
vie c'est la vie c'est la vie c'est fou
en 17 ou sous 17 de caspar en avis et en
dix-sept le fou il reste 20 minutes 20
minutes à kasparov contre 25 granic de
cette norme y réfléchisse trop là ils
vont perdre autant c'est n'importe quoi
mon service aussi bien des arbres et
bien mise à mal kasparov il est pressé
parce que quemener 4 x 30 m pour et 3
trams dit qu'il avait vu non mais la
torah si vite les lois saillie sur ces
pièces kasparov l'un n'allant retour
assez vite
il ya un problème stéphane c'est quand
même le cavadee revient en page 4 oui et
ont peut-être aller manger la tour on
s'est vite avec échec à ce genre de
choses
peut-être oui et non il va jouer il a eu
l'air de vouloir le jouer
par le jouer ton des saignements b6 et
b6 ici qu'est-ce qu'il va jouer là non
mais peut-être kasparov ramasse les
pions loi maintenant cavalier c'est
cette cavale et prendre des 5,1 kramnik
s'est fourvoyé une issue possible
non non c'est pas fourvoyé du tout
vladimir kramnik collèges quatre voyages
4 n'a pas l'air de faire grand chose
kasparov s'est levé à son tour aïe aïe
aïe non mais là ils sont réfléchis trop
de temps elle voit c'est n'importe quoi
là non mais là c'est n'importe quoi ce
qu'il ya de ce qui s'est passé
24 minutes chronique pour jouer 18 coups
qu'à découvrir la turquie aux 4 il va
jouer le 4 non non non c'est pas
possible
si je veux 4 c'est incroyable si j'ai
pris quatre c'est incroyable ce qu'il a
voulu jouer là on l'a vu mettre sa main
on n'a pas vu ce qu'ils voulaient
prendre
il vérifie vérifier quoi qu'est-ce
qu'ils vérifient torchio 2004 il se
passe quoi ces hauts cadres sur lequel
il peut pas bouger je comprends rien je
ne comprends plus rien 23.7 qui comprend
des cinq échecs et orange suite non ça a
pas l'air d'aller du tout ça n'a pas
l'air d'aller du tout ce qu'ils
voulaient jouer cavalier h 15 la ligne
de tram knicks à ce niveau si c'est non
il ramène le fond de l'étang aux 4,4
fait chaud c'est quoi l'idée 1 comprend
rien du tout
alors que les arbitres nous les garçons
mais ya pas de son il ya pas de son ce
n'est pas grave mais il suffit faut il
faut que yannick ferme le son je vais
pas vous en met le son va directement de
l'amont parle
allawi jo avant fait plutôt passif et
des moyens fou au 4 x 4 et kramnik la
jouer très vite
voilà stéphane c'est à n'y plus rien
comprendre
il veut peut-être j'aurais quand même
cavalier h4 il a des idées comique veut
un pétale aussi jouer cavalier en d4
après son discours il cloue toutes les
tous les cavaliers les deux foot
cramique sont beaux ils sont beaux ces
fous c'est remettre son jeu mais
kasparov il ya six ans à 0,6 à peu près
quand il veut pourquoi pas sûr aussi bas
si sa menace de prendre en v5
si on fait bien on prend et bien
comprendre la tour sortant les pièces
des noirs 2 km les deux caïds qui ce
prof sont forts aussi stéphane faut pas
oublier positionnement on peut prendre
une des scènes qui joue et qu'il avait
des caps n'ont rien à tour ses cartes
étant prise car oui d'accord avec dans
l'instant cependant la boue j'ai d'abord
mais c'est vrai qu'ils prendront des 5
c'est peut-être une mauvaise
positionnelle
kasparov et leur surprise darfour où
quatre un petit peu mais c'est
extrêmement extrêmement chaud il voici
a6 a6a y est c'est fait star of joue le
coup à six qui a l'air très fort il est
il est serein il est serein kasparov
ouais nan mais il réfléchit trop de
temps un chroniqueur c'est sûr et ses
fans qu est ce qui se passe sur a6
c'est chaud c'est chaud et on peut plus
parler donc arrêtez de parler dans ce
cas là non mais je n'ai peut-être quand
même 4 et de chic et de monstres ce
cavalier 4 non je pense que le bon truc
dans cette position ça va être de jouer
tours fc 1 mais non mais attention il
peut on prend un but 5 des voix puis on
prend bessin plongeant stage de cinq oui
direct comprend qu on prend et on prend
tout reprend et là je pense que il ya un
net avantage blanc hamon à lloret un net
avantage blanc parce qu'on va manger en
d5 la rupture isolée avec le kenya 3 sur
les cases des cas pour le bloquer et
ramassé est tombé 5 ap ap une position
techniquement gagnante
tu penses ouest mahler ça m'a l'air
assez clair je sais pas assez clair que
les blancs ne risque strictement rien
dans cette position peut-être on va tout
bloquer le chocolat
ouais
pas de problème ici pas de problème
oui c'est ça non ça c'était à peu près
ce qui était prévu stéphane c'était qu'
il fallait absolument que cramique
trouve une transformation une
transformation donc faut prendre ces
cinq c'était logique
donc je suis plus parler on en sait plus
trop surtout quand t'es sport ce n'est
pas assis mais qu'est ce qui dit plein
de tendresse pas possible effectivement
j'ai l'impression qu'on entend
extrêmement bien depuis la loge de
kasparov
mais il est cramique s'est jamais plaint
de quoi que ce soit en une chronique
s'en fout encore dit qu'il est en train
de gagner le match
ouais que pas joué
que va jouer de la lumière krainik
alors que semble-t-il
le réalisateur ne peut plus tenir
ni les arbitres ni kasparov a et c'est
normal c'est parce qu'il n'a plus sa
valise et vie c'est vrai qu'il a été
dans la valise tout était dans la valise
qu'il a perdu à l'aéroport confisqué
tous les moyens de pression alors que
kramnik ivresse 21e minute quand le
mandat il a vu quand il a vu la
conversion il a accordé huit minutes
wayne ne soit pas lerclerc ton histoire
la magie c'est extrêmement clair moi je
suis pas convaincu mais le proccessus
retour c'est ainsi on peut revenir à la
position
ils ne mesurent tour c'est un le truc c
qui est évidemment on prend avec le fou
en bessin qui s'est beaucoup plus subtil
nous nous occupions soit éloigné
stéphane oui bah tu n'auras pas fou pour
ses 5
si on prend comme france c'est sûr qu'on
peut pas combien de pièces en prison
projet autre chose mais bon tout reprend
ses 5
ouais alors je vois pas ce qui est
techniquement gagnant 1 c'est pas tes
compagnons mais il ya aucun problème
pour les grands ballets dire trois des
quatre c'est très fort ouais c'est très
très fort en la mélangeant tour c'est
vital et noir pour changer quelques
jours en quelques tours à ses huit tours
assez vite
c'est un retour à gérer on doit pas
jouer ça c'est vrai que ça peut faire
une tour et donc le cavalier des cinq
étant prises non mais la menace c'est
qu'il y ait des quatre qui attaquera le
food et celles qui ont aussi dit cela
car ces six parfums peut tout devrait
peut-être simplement tout ça c'est
positionnelle pour ramener qu'un nombre
bien c'est comme ça assiste vient d'être
trouvée par kasparov peut-être qu'il
envisage de prendre ces cinq tout de
suite qu'est-ce que non je pense pas je
pense qu'il va jouer à tours sa balle
trop jeune pour camille confejes dix
neuf minutes akram nique pour vrai mais
10 et la fois kasparov aussi 18 à kaspar
ans
quelle tension l'encan risque sadristes
dépasser le 40e ou alors dans une finale
très technique oui on attendait une
grosse
en attendant une grosse attaque mais non
en fait c'est quand même c'est un bon
défenseur solide expérience surtout
quand il ya plein de pièces voilà un
petit bilan pendant 19 minutes 25
secondes pour kramnik 18 minutes 33
christophe al aqra pour jouer tout ça
c'est énorme
alors il paraîtrait que leucate force
plein du son d'après les dernières
rumeurs parce que voudrait couper le
broadcast canal web pour avoir le
l'exclu d'exclusivité sur son site et
sur son site internet
effectivement bon site internet kasparov
après ce match ça sera pour les
nostalgiques
ça c'est dur alors que le fils de
kasparov
nous regarderons fiscale à la non mais
je sais pas comme il faut pour réfléchir
au tard l'heure qu'il est c'est donc le
premier c'est ça va jouer tellement vite
après qu'on pourra pas suivre emploi
vous suivre c'est sûr ça va jouer très
vite
non mais là ça va encore sa voie en
amenant mais il ya une minute park où
stéphane ne faut pas faut pas dramatiser
plus que ça mais par coup c'est madonna
bon on va prendre la grande liquidation
c'est certain maintenant le liquid à
sion le liquid hishon surcouf aux quatre
amis qu'il fasse attention parce qu'il
peut y avoir des retours de bâton aussi
s'il fait patent si je met en scène un
thermique va le faire et puis on prend
ainsi c'est pas bon si on prend ainsi
c'est possible aussi c'est une autre
nuit à tour prend tout en france et 5
puis on prend un tour cn c'est ça qu'il
envisage aussi chronique et aprica ayant
4 je me demande vraiment je ne comprends
pas mes espaces line 3 6
ça a l'air très surprenant retour trop
on prend ces 5
départ à jouer comme francis mais voilà
il ajoute je reprend 1,6 les jouets puis
on prend l'air dû sinon hallucinant de
l'animatronique hallucinant ce coup
c'était intenable ça parfaitement
intenable ce soir vous reprendre la tour
tout de suite très vite et la chronique
va jouer il faut penser ça qu'on voit
pas ce qu'il peut faire d'autre le foot
attaqué faut pas qu'il oublie on peut
prendre ces 5 et entraîna dame sera
cassé une baisse est stéphane comme tu
sert à quoi abbas a mis la pression ces
attaques des 5 et assainissement c'était
une double menace c'est un ancien nom
français 5 voilà c'est fait 36 cents
mais à tourbes et si sûr de l'opposition
qui voit tomber si oui alors on comprend
voila voila on peut prendre des cinq
avant aussi prendre des cinq puis on
prend les dom vayssette voit les tours
des six tournées n'ya pas toi qu'est-ce
qu'il ya quoi les patrons des six
français cinq l'instauration d'un
entretien des jeux toi ça c'est la
langue qu'on avait prévu ouais ouais et
on s'en félicite
oui bien et bien c'est sûr chou oui mais
là on rentre dans une position beaucoup
plus calme en granit et encore la
pression mais oui il est toujours de la
pression sur
oui mais de la pression mais mais mais
mais kasparov en plus oui c'est un fait
donc là je pense qu'il joue et ours et 6
donc c'est 6 et passifs c'était un tour
ses huit tours s'est vite
alors c'est vite ses fans il ya un joli
à il ya plein de contrepoint 30 ans
habitant va le montrer j'ai l'impression
qu'il a tout repensé simplement fait ce
n'est pas sûr on va montrer sa tour
prend ses cinq as we taux prend way et
là on peut jouer pour le thème du mat du
couloir avec dame échec un échec et sur
x huit on prend ces 5 comprend un
système mais là le problème c'est que
c'est nous c'est dire si la dame qui
vient prendre ces cinq on prend 1,8
échec et mat noir wave et ac/dc les
noirs qui mate en premier
donc ça c'est pas acceptable rares en
revanche sinon s'appellera jjg dans
cette pression de tout repenser 5 et 6
passes les fans jeu à oui bah c'est ça
la dame prend et bien contrôler avec
assez vite
donc ça surtout on peut jouer tour s'est
vite donc j'espère que je m'attends
sabic n'essaie pas dans cette position
le client mais tout est parfait pour
l'ange la torah 5
mais rien de plus je ne sais pas s'il a
envie de rejouer avec sa tour des huit
tonnes + bon il est un endroit un peu en
l'air mais il ya en plus une tasse pas
ses oreilles parler parce qu'il doit
toujours prévoir qu'elle venait à 4 tout
le temps non mais c'est pas très grave
mais non gorgés vite rangé mitsuhashi
cet échec
bref cet oued ou ouais c'est vrai c'est
chaud très chaud toujours prévoir ce à
tout moment le cavalier peut pas en dire
sur les 15 h 4 et ramasser la mise au
chaud trop chaud trop chaud pour
travailler 16 minutes contre 17 à 14
coups va jouer on a envie d'atteindre le
40e coup pour pouvoir se reposer
c'est la tension aujourd'hui
kasparov en termes plus ce qui est mieux
toujours caspar enfin finalement
kasparov
il a gardé son petit on va garder non
mais il s'accroche là parce qu'il sait
que
c'est que ça peut jouer là non ou alors
il est sûr que non kasparov
effectivement servi pour l'instant c'est
a priori lui qui est celui qui peut
gagner la cbi qui peut gagner
à noter quand même que si jamais
cramique récupère le clan c'est sans
doute un extrait très léger en avantage
symbolique mais un avantage plus que
symbolique on voit pas ce que peu gras
ni peut en faire non je ne vois pas trop
comment je sais pas qui est mieux en
fait aucune idée je pense que les noirs
sont mieux parce qu'ils ont plus en plus
il pleut granik n'a vu
rien pu démontrer à verser je crois que
j'ai achetés pour ces huit femmes sont
que montrer la position dont la position
alors que kasparov docteur s'est vite
oui il est bien que je verrais bien un
coup comme dame ces deux tout simplement
oui attaquant le pion 600 atteints sur
ces cinq
l'idée c'est que sur tours à cinq je
peux probablement joué d'amenée d'eau
qui attaquera et la tour et le cavalier
on double menace est sûre tronche et 6
alors son tour ses sites j'ai pas
vraiment envisagé ce coup j'avais
envisagé plutôt calé des quatre qui
permet cette fois te reprends des cas
vont être finalement ça marche mais ça
marche là donc ici je ne sais pas c'est
possible c'est deux tours c'est chiche à
noter que l'ordinateur sur temps s'est
vite lui mentionne qu'à 10 h 4 sur et
oui mais ça sans idée apparemment sans
idées pour s'éviter possible garry
kasparov
oui mais alors là voilà c'est là
justement c'est le fameux retournement
de situation stéphane kasparov passe une
position où il était sous pression a
priori moins bien à une position il est
sous pression mais a priori mieux et ça
change tout pour lui aussi introduire
estimation des ventes deux nuls
il doit les éliminer alors qu'avant ils
étaient ils les accepter harry est donc
là il faut que je suis beaucoup plus de
choses ah oui c'est vrai que c'est lui
qui passe à un éventuel mode attaque
c'est ça exactement
donc il reste treize minutes contre 17 à
kramnik et peut-être les noirs sont
mieux c'est ne retournement des roms
sont des expressions pas mieux mais ils
ont une opportunité de jouer
à noter sur dame ces 2 l'ordinateur pour
pascal vallée b si c'est loin angers qui
rendrait le pion nom puisqu'elle met du
couloir à la fin maintenant on va
attendre et psion pas de mac du couloir
sa réaction c'est être si elle va du
coup leur avis de pardon non mais si les
tours sa vie après thor ce séminaire est
assez vite mais alma du couloir raison
donc et coup
tours s'est vite kasparov la non 305 3 5
le coup qu'il préfère garry kasparov 3,5
à noter que cette espérance ne gagne pas
à la conférence de presse il va être
bouillonnant homme il va dire qu'il
était mieux quel séjour
c'est super chaud bon cela de s'être
calmés quand même il me semble plus pour
les noirs voilà
et un de plus pour les noirs et on voit
pas pourquoi pas malheureusement comment
les blancs c'est sa chronique c'est
peut-être emballé alors il a l'air
d'être un peu plus relâchée quel sport
13 minutes kasparov contre 16,1
chronique pour jouer 14e coup
que va faire cramer un trafic sous
pression indiscutablement la chronique
doit être sous pression
maintenant pourquoi il réfléchit au
temps pour arriver à cette position
pourquoi telle réfléchir autant pour
jouer ces merdes c'est toute la question
qu'on peut se poser stéphane javalet h4
mais pourquoi mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il
a pris en mains si c'est ça qui est
incroyable puisqu'il atteindra kasparov
l'opportunité de la teinture en c5 et
bêtement sans kévin estre ans est
muselée alors qu'avant ils allaient en
décapitant faute j'ai pas un cheval il
pouvait jouer on va jouer pour ces
alsaciens à peut-être peut-être voilà
une faute peut-être cramique aurait fait
une faute c'est possible eh bien
peut-être on va assister à un
retournement dans le match
rami va essayer de gagner risque de
perdre malgré cela ils ont le sens hyper
motivés hypermotivés kasparov en
reviendrait dans le match ce serait la
nouvelle d'aujourd'hui
si on peut le montrer les garry kasparov
c'est un gros retournement de situation
kramnik s'est emballé il a mis des
annonces et les naïades akram nicolas
kaczmarow way kramnik gens seraient
emballés
vas-y vas-y bien maintenant c'est cuit
le problème c'est qu'on a vu que essayé
d'arrêter son fils à la tête des bons
jours à fêter de selena lagarrigue
kramnik n'a pas trouvé le moyen de
passer à la
la femme dit peu cette fin de l'opus en
ont simplement par chaque fois je dois
je crois comme ça attendre de vouloir ne
rien faire là dès mercredi mais ça
demande un certain sang-froid de rien
faire dans cette position quand on met
lentement en général on essaie de faire
quelque chose pour la version 6 crown
ici quatre offres marquent un point ça
relance entièrement le match
ce serait horrible
boukrami nick wey
ils marquent pas les pièces noires sur
tout ça ça laisse aka sport deux fois
les pièces blanches pour revenir
notamment donnant grave deux défaites
consécutives ça serait le craquage
cramique se serait emballé dame 17 c'est
pas mal non
même les scènes cfa que je crois qu'il y
ait quelques problèmes
pourquoi problème si les salaires de
paralyser les noirs un peu non dom
vayssette
nous avons besoin de plus la sagan oui
ça gagne en plus tranquille quoi bas ça
gagne c'est difficile à dire si on
commence à avancer la mairie gagner
facilement
mais oui mais comme moi mais là les
sports va se regrouper et d'abbayes lui
c'est simple il va jouer d'amd si ce
n'est celui de tourbe et 8
oui ça y est
fini quoi ils se regroupent coin c'est
fini je vais dp6 après ces quatre îles
est cuite en équipe ben oui il est cuit
granby qui cuit dom vayssette ça a l'air
d'être une des chances
kasparov a gobé le pion il a gardé en
sandales 17 saddam des six très simple
oui c'est sa force gary et 7ème bbc1
on voit pas comment les blancs peuvent
s'en sortir bon je pense qu'il va jade
mc2 peut-être enfin nick wey mais la
dame cdd dam des deux et on en fait eu
mon chum on enfume pas grand-chose à
fait moyen
dom ces deux il ya toujours ces huit
noms tout simplement alors certes on
s'est mutée vadam d2 qu'est ce qui se
passe sur mc do dans cette position je
ne sais pas mais de façon il ya aucune
variante qui donne quoi que ce soit aux
blancs pourquoi les blancs ont fait puis
on prend ainsi c'est peut-être ça la
faute tu allais cette variante royal
crown nick la préparation de kramix
aurait réfuté par quatre au maroc
stéphane je viens de voir il s'en donne
ses 2 vient de voir une explication
d'enfer voilà donc dans cette position
car mon club fléchi surnomment ses 2 eh
bien il a fait dan dah les deux dames
venues s'amuser comme ces hausses à
perdre et mais qu avec l idée la dante
de l'homme v2 l'idée qu'il fallait jouer
un coup stéphane à 6-6 mais il menace
tour des dames des 2 et même des deux
cci de replacer la demande une attaque
dans la tour et après bienvenue
ouais alors je vais vous montrer la
variante quand même la variante s'était
ainsi on allait en c2 dans la place il y
avait kamel b 6 très joli coup en qu'un
début si ce tout simplement et surtout
reprend 16 ans ont joué tout reprend
tout reprend dame prend et tour s'éviter
tour s'est vite les magistrats jolie la
tour va apprendre la torah en c1
et là c'est terminé sur deux chronos
tout repenser nos bacs alors ils
allaient jouer kasparov
non mais pas louis non il a traduit
quelques jeunes des deux rôles là il
reste douze minutes rappelé par off pour
jeu 13 coups contre onze minutes 55
chronique et après dame b 2-1 sparrow
qu'est-ce qu'on fait mieux
voilà grave
l'ordinateur dit qu'il faut jouer un
coup de fouet kasparov c'est vrai que
david et de menaces x 8 x 8 ou fausse et
6 ouais mais c'est à leur bon salaire
suffisant quand ils sont pas fous ces
six il peut pas y avoir
d'hab c'est long quand même rangnick est
raide
cram nick est raide pas sûr quand même
pas sur leurs actes et spa en fil rouge
pas à les nommer life et la tête du
joueur qui va gagner castrophe c'est
vrai il faut le dire ça serait sa
première victoire dans ce marché se
serait donc sur une défense bien dommage
pour chroniques comme ça c'est une
victoire sur une défense oui
dans la chronique est raide à moins
qu'ils nous sortent la grosse défense n
ya pas de raison kasparov en a bien
sauvé 2 c'est vrai
non mais là c'est pas c'est pas
forcément finie stefano pas non mais
c'est hyper dur à défendre à nîmes pas
c'est clair quoi et le roi noir ça
serait plusieurs points noirs le pion
passé que défendre je ne sais pas non
non c'est pas évident du tout à gagner
ses positions il ya encore des
affaiblissements ya encore des choses
qui doivent se passer
c'est vrai qu'elle aura noir qu'elles
peuvent s'occuper de saddam b2c très
bien trouver de la part d'autres
américains faut bien vivre c'est un coup
tranquille quoi en fait
s'améliorant de la fraîcheur de la dame
ça profite de la torah 5 métiers
stéphane ces femmes quoi il dira un plan
bien le plan fut bien aidé mc2 on peut
le montrer
ou bien aidé à même ses deux batteries
dame sous menace d'un match 7 mc doom
menace une
une rentrée si on mesure bien sûr oui
oui des contre attaques possibles à ces
choo t j'ai mal au ventre
ça me stresse trop
ça me stresse trop ces deux parties il
reste dix minutes à place parole pour
louer 13 coups et 11 minutes 55
chronique
ah oui non mais surtout que dams et 2
met la pression sur ses 5 également fou
mais un c'est très très subtil d'un
certain gary ne passera pas marc est pas
clair la passe et c'est superbe et tous
à trouver une vitesse remarquable
non m a dit qu six ans or il aurait eu
chaud hein ouais mais bon c'est ça c'est
bien parce que ça va lui au moins
cramique il va se dire bon c'est le
moment où le calme le jeu maintenant ils
s'excitent leghari je vais pas le
chauffer davantage je fais nul demain je
fais nul après demain et je me marre
voilà voilà le plan de vladimir kramnik
dans ce match à aca soir à fait non de
la tête 1-1 d'un lever de sa selle pour
les supposés problèmes et qu'ils y
restent
il reste neuf minutes à kaspar ans pour
jouer presque ou non mais tout est
possible et loire c'est comme cette
pagani non mécanique peut gagner mais
kasparov aussi non mais là c'est hyper
pose tout est possible il reste très peu
de temps joueurs pour faire des gaffes
exactement en même temps c'est ce qu'on
aime dans leurs rangs une gaffe sur
notre ami nicolas girard est un fan de
dégâts non mes doigts avec l'ordinateur
nous dit qu'il me gave on doit le voir
tout de suite ce sera rideau tombé saint
tropez sec surprenant annonce était un
des coûts pour proposer envisagée par
mal tourner si il y à damas trois à
l'ats stefan le coin où dame c2 où il ya
beaucoup de concurrents ni tomber sa
mme13 avec l idée d data question 7 5
dans un premier temps et de jouer
ensuite faut bien une dame des trois
niveaux
j'ai mal j'ai mal pour les joueurs la
caisse par ofi doute là il doute quand
même il arbore une île sauvage à saddam
rideau il commence à douter parce que ça
sonnait se désorganise un peu c'est
yacine dessins qu'il n'avait pas envie
de le faire tomber ces super show hyper
chaud même attention à ce que si les
noirs
si les bleus ne jouent pas d'âme b2b
toujours le coup comme les v6 non si
j'ai pas beaucoup me plaindre d'un à
trois dames à 3 que les v6 ça marche pas
donc on s'échauffe fort que les blancs
quand même se prémunissent du match du
couloir c'est vrai que quand même
embêtant haut lieu ouais ce matelas il
leroy la halle aux draps blancs ils se
promettent du couloir si ça continue on
l'a l'ordinateur mans sur la vente
d'armes à 3 qui avait b6 tour des quatre
ça chauffe pour d4
mais puisque si on prend il ya le même
thème d'aléatoire joué par k o
à quelque 6 tempo de gloucester of show
tempo oui tempo qui aimait cissé qui se
passe sur 3 ans et 5 et bien on va
l'expliquer c'est le mode du couloir ou
encore qui ressurgit
surtout qu'on sait s'en servir actuelle
il ya 30 autour de sodexo l'ordinateur
dit ici poussé 6 à weepu c6 vos rangs
hallucinant et oui alors la tour est
cloué à la tourette louer et madame le
deux tours menace de faire des maths du
couleurs il ya des mains du couloir dans
tous les coins ouais ouais c'est pas lui
c'est pas mal ça aussi si tu gagnes une
pièce se sent ici l'ordinateur 10 tours
des quatre dans cette position ont été
retracés ory cette partie taurine leur
show la dame est cloué par des clous et
c'est monstrueux c'est monstrueux cette
forme parti reste le reste neuf minutes
55 à 36 minutes
kasparov complètement dingue
complètement dingue cette fin de partie
à kramnik ne peut pas se prémunir du mat
du couloir pour l'instant et qu'est ce
qui se passe sur tour des quatre pour d4
sa menace rien mais les noirs n'ont plus
trop grand chose sinon mais les noirs
jouent tout simplement eloi dames 8 par
exemple elle invite sa percée 5e non
comment ah si on peut en effet retrouvé
un chèque lire parce qu'il ya le fond
qui contrôle le fou aux 4 qui contrôle
il est beau ce fou et ténor peuvent pas
jouer f5 alors f5 s'est encore affaiblie
sans ia cavadeos avec tout de suite un
minaret non me adam f 6 et loi oui non
alors tu veux dire après tour des quatre
f5
oui le four reviendrait peut-être en d3
avec un ton aulas est compliqué c'est
compliqué il faut que copé kramnik joue
autour des 4 11 moncheaux mons 3
manchots et moi j'ai mal partout en
corse stéphane bouillon le plus
tellement j'ai de stress là cette
pendule il restait huit minutes
non mais ces idées extrêmes utiliser la
cram me contre 9 minutes à kas parents
évidemment là plus personne n'ose lève
le match atteint son sommet actuellement
c'est incroyable ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est le sommet du match ils
ont 12 coups à jouer en 9 minutes et la
position est d'une complexité rare
garry kasparov et mieux est-ce qu'il va
réussir à l'emporter
c'est l'enjeu des prochains coups
stéphane c'est hyper chaud c'est la
première partie qui est aussi tendue
c'est vrai ben voilà c'est extrême ces
extrêmes au niveau de la pendule au
niveau de la pendule si tu as fait un
sens c'est ce qui se passe qu'on va
jouer très à noter que notre tour
descartes on trouve tout de suite mais
pour qu'en dit que c'était une finale
dans mes chroniques la vue évidemment
mais
ils vérifient ton satyajit ray oppose la
machine pour 2,4 g 5 cas vu la machine
rapide
si tu as peur tu joues g5 et bien
comprendre a absolument rien c'est dit
je sais que l'air quand même du coup
j'ai juste 5 à l'air comment dire
stéphane bern hâtivement et du coup
c'est un coup bas ça ressemble à la
partie dû aux 6 ou gsm qui était mauvais
c'est la télévision internet ils ont
donc g5 avec un album autour des 4 as
des chroniques sept minutes 37 min pour
les douze coups contre un déficit non
mais là c'est sûr canal des jours qui va
perdre il y avait des voir un chrétien
jusqu'au là je parie sur une perte de
chronique parce que la trop de réflexion
non mais reste que sept minutes a craqué
pour jeu 12 coups il vague a fixé sur la
nature ne nous dispense aussi un peu
après tour des quatre caisses qui joue
qu'espéré qu'est-ce qui joue il ya plein
coup j'ai scène par exemple non mais
j'ai cinq jeux pour les blancs je ne
comprends pas ce que font les blancs aux
menaces ou des trois tours des quêtes
mais c'est pas français ça n'est pas de
match de couleur annoncée puisque le
foot en d3 je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas personne ne comprend
depuis personne ne comprend ce qui se
passe ailleurs et six minutes 6 minutes
à 13 me contre 2,9 à kasparov si vous
êtes en direct c'est intenable
il reste douze coups à jouer à deux
joueurs ça veut dire qui a plu
réfléchissent plus de perdre à la
pendule
c'est un moment intense si la partie
encore hyper complexe c'est un temps
sera mis qu'un pur de moins laurent noir
de kasparov est faible donc c'est très
tendu grammy qui allez faut jouer
d'abord faut jouer à g pas il va pas
s'en sortir vladimir est clair six
minutes maintenant c'est un problème
c'est qu'à moindre faute est sanctionnée
tout de suite six minutes restantes pour
venir
un groupe non mais c'est trop signé et
on file à trois minutes de plus il me
tourne plus c'est terminé 30 % davantage
mais aussi chroniqueuse autour des 4 et
qu'il a tout calculé non mais on avait
vu tout à l'heure il n'y a pas tout
calculer puisqu'il construit là tout
calculé allez allez allez dehors des
quatre vite que kasparov a cédé les
idées dans la pose du leader l'anglais
serial killer le fameux tueur en série a
les hommes qui avaient battu trois fois
de suite dans un match aux championnats
du monde va-t-il réitérer l'exploit
était possible avec kasparov oblique
foule à laval a dit attention horrible
alors quand vous allez nantes on sait
que kasparov et quand même phénoménal à
cette partie n'est phénoménal kasparov à
une note il peut tout faire c'est la 12e
partie du match c'est les héritable
peut-être le retournement du match
krainik s'est embourbé vous bourre mais
alors il trouve pas un homme c'est
horrible y aurait choisi cette race très
mal on a très très mal pour les joueurs
5,48
non monsieur m possible quoi ces profils
va compliquer au maximum tout simplement
il va la voir où on veut l'avoir lavée
pour base ou pas quand ni qu il allait
trois des six coups pour ces 3 et là
dans une hauteur alors j'ai tout de
suite pensé trans a pas l'air terrible
il a hésité très longtemps trop tourné
trois tours des casques quoi secouer
dans ces trois c'est un coup alternatif
on me dit c'est un coup par défaut non
il a il a bien réfléchi
la menace de travnik ch 3 et reprend 7 5
et non oui oui stéphane calais c'est la
case b4 libre si on peut montrer là et
qu'on arrive à jouer cavalier des cours
m lecavalier
c'est la menace oui c'est la menace ils
activerait son cavalier va mieux après
non mais ils chassent la touriste
français 5 ha oui oui mais la cahc sport
que je veux ou celles qui n'ont que
propose x 8,6 il faut 8 il ya eu des
caps n'ont faut vite il semblerait
qu'elle ait des quatre anneaux via le
mode du couloir comme en mai mais ouais
oui on ne comprend pas un comprend pas
mais c'est extrêmement extrêmement
compliqué donc pas rester huit minutes
et 8 pour qu'elle se méritait pas ce
n'est qu'espoir va peut-être pas jouer
le meilleur coût maintenant il va mettre
la pression et sucre à munich oui la vie
est le plus fort en asie note la
stratégie adoptée généralement par les
joueurs ces deux rien fait oui c'est de
rien faire parce que justement ça laisse
à l'autre même s'ils ont tendance à être
des reclassements fait rien je suis
comme je le crains ni qu'il ait joué h3c
enlève tous les matchs du court en
organique un coût beaucoup plus utile
que j'espère signer un coup il a un coût
de joker ouais il est un coup de poker
ch3 cocasse parole c'est hyper chaud
stephen c'est vraiment non mais c'est
vraiment une des plus belles parties au
niveau intensité de l'émotion il y en a
tant il reste onze coups à jouer au
scrabble jeux qui reste 5 minutes 7
minutes à kaspar ans qui est incroyable
c'est une chronique à un pur - granny
capture - mais peut-être que les joueurs
dépensent pour jouer les coûts
d'impression la passion c'est un vrai
championnat du monde
j'ai mal aux 41e verbal au sort qui
serait en gagnent il revient dans le
match tombait 4 b 4 attention quand
l'option ses seins qui tombent et 4
pourquoi ce qui n'est pas en crise
l'option c5 stefan hell à l'ordinateur
tro breizh tacle fois aux quatre cas
validé deux jeux le parc ramic quelle
honte et ça ça ressemble à la gaffe
stéphane hénon pas tout de suite ça
ressemble à une gaffe ce côté des deux
jeux revenir en c4 il veut bloquer à
nouveau bloquées et des deux un coup que
casque ans n'a pas dû prévoir
voilà d'ailleurs on le voit on le voit à
l'écran il n'a pas dû prévoir ce goûter
et des deux il reste qu à jouer
il a dit qu à jouer c'est extrêmement
mais extrêmement compliqué il ya
peut-être que deux personnes sur terre
capable de jouer cette position dans le
temps qu'ils ont ils bien c'est kasparov
et krainik et là oh lalala signe de
transparence contre 5 pour cramique 6
millions là sein de joux à la seconde
près il reste dix coups à jouer non
médicaux jouer ça va être horrible
horrible ça va être insoutenable c'est
déjà le plus la mairie kasparov la casse
qui va faire ça y est bien en cours
d'une 4,54 pour chroniques contre la
pendule d'amd chine c'est pas mal de
défis il va jouer kasparov là ça serait
bien qu'on le voit en train de jouer on
a vu ça demain passer là ne légifèrent
ensemble aux gagnants et loi précise que
les c4 annonc é s et 4 perdrait tout de
suite oui thème des 6,6 à tour des 3
stéphane à huy tous mes trente et un ans
bien ça on respire pour inspire à moitié
on respire pas trop j'espère qu'il a
fait un nom de la tête encore wayne à
noter que là il a plus que 50 secondes
avance kasparov évidemment des secondes
ça passe plus vite que les minutes après
j'ai super mal au ventre
1 c'est par le stress dans laquelle on
jeunes ont des sports fait non de la
tête
il fait non
est non mais c'est pas possible été
surpris par qualité d'autres chroniques
ça c'est sûr ça va venir s est mineur 20
kasparov contre 4 minutes 54 g ni
qu'elle tienne intensité dix coups à
jouer ils attention ils seront ses
remarques shibam ici alors que c'était
plus un bruit dans la salle le public ne
respire même plus il faut tel le 40e
coup pour les joueurs pour avoir une
heure de réflexion de plus j'en ai c'est
phénoménal
et là il ya dix quoi jouer en moins de
dix minutes c'est parfait qui s'avance
attention dans cinq secondes
ashcroft ramener en tant que technique
voilà attention et chronique est à
l'affût 2-1 égalité de macramé qu'il a
envie de jouer c'est page 3 et tout ça
il a joué f5
ça ressemble s'assemble à
l'affaiblissement f5 alors là
l'ordinateur annonce dans ses cinq ans
cette forme d'astaro forêt fait un
mauvais coup non en tant qu'entité une
tourte rend fou tu en penses même temps
qu'un cap cavani préemption prend et on
ne voit pas on ne voit pas olivier
fosseux 34 3 me non pour fo est royal
yacht est certes reprendre ses scènes
quand même incroyable entre 1,12 à faire
trop pensé ça existe je le reste dix
coups à jouer stéphane prend ses singles
je suis hyper complète à la france et
c'est une chronique va faire trop
prendre sessègnon chronique va jouer il
faut s 3 3
hyper chaud il ya quatre minutes akram
nick camp de quatre minutes 5 ans vont
en effet avoir les plans le gros enjeu
c'est l'option c5 ici quand et qui a
fait non de la tête aussi a envoyé la
position la position sont vite la
position rapidement très vite voilà
voilà la position ont touché aucune
pièce et le wave 3 c'est possible tours
france et 5 c'est possible c'est le gros
enjeu de cette position c'est son option
on peut prendre ici mais les noirs
récupérer une pièce
oui d'abord je voudrais tout reprendre
fou il ya joué qu'en effet imagerie il
valide il a joué faux f3 je fais pas
trop pensé scène qu'un jouet corner 37
ans fait quel effet si le fait non c'est
pas il a noté très vite on est certain
d'être pansées 5 et il fait non la tête
kasparov russe mais qu'est ce qui s'est
dit plus tard enfin j'ai mal il a une
minute d'avancé j'ai ramené plus haut
c'est bien au nom de ce qui lui arrive
chi chi le arrêter d arrêt qui s'est
garé ma place par au comité lecteurs
donc vers le client y perd le pian csn
peut-être c'est ça mais non il ya tous
ces habitants quand stéphane hénon
autour ces 8es doigt pour ses 8
qu'est ce qu'il a oublié caracas par
entoure ces 8
qu'est ce qui veut dire qu est ce qui
veut dire je suis parent seulement des
mots je serai quatre minutes restantes
pour jouer neuf coups gary kasparov dans
le caractère compliqué s'il avoue qu'il
arrive il ne s'est rien passé
d'exceptionnel stefan gysel s'est rien
passé et kasparov
à un peu plus de cinq ans maintenant
c'est pas bon il s'est même pas donné de
sur ces cinq années en prison stephano
sur ces cinq là donc c'est 8 à leur
force est donc allé à quatre c'est
possible sinon non cavalia 4 ya stoppant
c'est simple tout en pension quand même
mais alors surtout ses 8
ce n'est pas tout penser ça il n'y a pas
tant mais qu'est-ce qu'il n'y a rien
donc pour lui et qu'ils n'arrivent pas
bien camille coton sanitaire of 3
minutes 30 à kasparov contre 3 minutes
40 acres à munich pour jouer neuf coups
donc une pièce d'anton à 10h au granit 9
crespin fait non de la tête
et stéphane fait ce qu'on peut imaginer
kasparov gaffe
oui une vrai gamin mais oui fcd
fausse-garde l'informatique il veut pas
jouer tour s'est vite ça veut dire qu'il
n'a pas vu ou alors qu'il un matin elle
cela attention est ce que craint
attention il faut commenter kasparov là
stéphane la messe que kramnik peut jouer
la partie s'ils gagnent le pion oui
abomination maintenant la case au sein
qui affaiblit oui la classe de ce1 qui a
fait mal mais je dirais qu'il a des
chances de gains non mais objectivement
oui ça sera thierry cela peut se
retrouver moins bien ça serait terrible
donc ça serait ça serait l'horreur d'un
mix soir jour il faut huit attaquants de
cavaliers non mais ça peut changer ça va
changer d'un instant à l'autre les
joueurs vont speed et c'est le cas de le
dire
incroyable incroyable garry kasparov qui
réfléchit deux minutes sur les 5-6
pourquoi ici sont pas tristes peut-être
mais que se passe-t-il dans sa tête il
faut qu'on finisse par tour 6 8 a l'air
de se tourner dans tous les sens il
n'arrête pas de bouger ses 8 août ces
huit dames des six aussi alors bon on
fait tout et pourquoi en fait débat et
pourquoi il s'inquiète la garder non
mais il voulait pas donner la case aux
cinq kasparov il y avait cru près de la
cage aux siens calais la pendule 2
minutes 20 à 15 par an contre 3 minutes
40 attractions et il reste neuf coups à
jouer
stéphane mais qu'est ce qu'il ya mais
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'il
fait pour mériter ce n'est pas renvoyé
au tijd note a commencé à bouger comme
ça alors que cramique va avoir deux fois
plus de temps que lui non mais craint ni
pourquoi il
non mais il a craqué sports ont fait
retraite dorée qui fait un bien fou mais
qui devient fou et le roi donne un fou
il essaie de se re motiver garry
kasparov
il va jouer un coup quand même me disait
un coup là pourquoi il fait tout ça la
bbc s'était alors que ça a pas l'air
c'est peut-être qu'il est stressé parce
qu'il a dit quoi joue en deux minutes
stéphane sadak le stress minute quarante
minutes 40 pour jouer m comme c'est
terrible pour mr d'or et si on n'y
arrive pas trop se réveille en fait
l'écart me fait ça parce qu'ils se
réveillent ils l'ont mais il essaie de
se réveiller
quid bougez bougez garry kasparov
stadiers à jouer qui veut dire plus
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup comme il
ya quatre n'est pas tout repenser centre
stéphane je ne comprends pas ton procès
cinq égal c'est en français 5 également
mentionnés par l'ordinateur prend ses 5
qu'est ce qu'il a vu surtout repenser 5
kasparov mais il a rien vu chronique non
mais alors qu'est-ce qui lui a appris à
garry kasparov
il reste 3 minutes 20 acres amis alors
l'abitre l'arbitré est venu près des
joueurs puisque si l'un des joueurs
tombent donc c'est terminé on peut en
profiter pour parler fort
il vient aussi de lancer cinq têtes
groupe djak ramener voilà il l'a fait
crâne y prend le pion ça va aller très
vite la tour b 2 qu'est ce qui se passe
en tribunes
lorsque les blancs sont venus des fans
kbc cap maintenant on ricane 6,4 à l'air
d'être le coup c'est le bouquet et ses
quatre amis que la vue évidemment qu'ils
veulent jouer prendre ça protège la dame
en plus il reste une minute 26 à 4h30 à
chroniquer sekkat il l'a fait il l'a
fait de la dynamique dame prend d'un
procès cinq kasparov veut faire nul ne
le sait
voilà comment c'était chaud or c'était
très très chaud stéphane et je crois que
là c'était là les joueurs sont les
questions restent eux sur scène c'était
extrêmement chaud extrêmement chaud
c'est extrêmement chaud et ils ont fini
par faire annuler ces sports s'il a
failli ça y est voilà revenue de loin
avec travnik on vient aussi pour signer
il était cagoulé je réside signer leurs
feuilles et pourquoi kramnik la joue pas
on va aller parce que c'est égal ils
sont obligés de changer les dames et
c'est une nulle s'était fait une bulle
scorant on peut le dire c'était nul
extrêmement sport mais je crois que la
cram migrants reviennent de loin
voilà donc on peut peut-être une fois
que les joueurs auront signé leurs
feuilles et je vomis achète vous
commenter un petit peu les derniers
coups voilà les joueurs sont partis on
va vous commentez moins quelques
instants les liens des coûts stéphanois
y voyant un petit peu les derniers coups
donc si on peut mettre la position
l'échiquier de démonstration or le voilà
donc ce qui s'est passé et bien c'était
comme ça casse parfait jouer f5 et après
fouet straw a commencé à gigoter dans
tous les sens et on n'a toujours pas
compris pourquoi on va nous l'expliqué à
la conférence de presse
5e tour c'est 8 alors bon il dit s'il
n'a pas joué le coup tours s'est vite
qu'ils défendent est l'option c5 qui
était la base de sa position et après
cavaliers il a joué comme il ya qu'a
péri kasparov qui a l'air de forcer la
nulle on est quelques trains dit qu'ici
bien entendu jouent toutes fonctions ces
cinq exactement
profitant du fait le tour des quatre ne
soit plus défendu sika soir veut
reprendre ses cinq ça devient très chaud
pour lui puisque après la prise de la
tour des quatre les blancs pour être
mieux loti de tourbe et de garry
kasparov attaque apparemment toutes les
pièces puisqu'il n'y a pas qu'elle qui a
aidé 2 et la tour c 504 annick se défend
précis jeu qu'avait laissé 4 contre
attaque sur l'autoroute a15 tour et
après d'un procès 5 de 14
les joueurs font nul - être pourquoi
bien parce qu'ici forcer ces dames
programme cavalli prend qu'avaient les
pentes où en est là en finale
on peut difficilement dire quand même
que l'affaiblissement de la classe de 5e
joué un rôle quelconque moyen
donc ici une ultra logique magnifique
superbe fight superbe au fight super
bris alors que là on attend la
conférence de presse en stephen je
compte vraiment j'ai du mal à reprendre
mon souffle
la conférence de presse va être
extrêmement chaude d'ailleurs je vais
tout de suite aller voir ce qui se passe
en te laissant conclure tout à fait
voilà un arbitre qui donne au micro les
joueurs doivent être dans un état de
tension terrible cette partie très très
tendue kasparov aurait pu l'emporter
kasparov aurait pu gagner cette partie
il s'est défendu bec et ongles kramnik
qui avait une grosse attaque et qui
s'est vu opposer une grosse défense de
kasparov
c'était très chaud
c'était très très chaud granic a donné
un pion et malheureusement pour lui son
attaque n'est pas passée et kasparov a
failli a failli l'emporter
heureusement que chronique s'est défendu
bec et ongles pour éviter la défaite
c'était une partie très tendue où il
restait plus que quelques minutes aux
deux joueurs pour jouer les derniers
coups
à quelle partie de la naphtaline 1 500
mc